as president biden readies to sign the
trillion dollar infrastructure bill he's
contending with a slew of economic
issues from the pandemic fallout
including rising prices and supply chain
shortages but now there's a new snag as
a record number of americans are
quitting their jobs during a nationwide
labor shortage
christina raffini has details on this
from the white house christina good
morning to you
good morning jeff well the white house
says that transportation bill that
passed the house last week is going to
help keep america on the road to
economic recovery but consumer
confidence is shaky amid rising consumer
prices and a labor shortage as millions
of americans around the country fed up
with low wages and bad working
conditions simply say i quit it will
create millions of new jobs will grow
the economy in a meeting with massed up
cabinet members president biden said
yesterday the bipartisan infrastructure
bill still yet to be signed will help
curb rising consumer prices we'll see
ease and i say yes ease lower
inflationary pressures on our economy
but even before his pen has hit that 1.2
trillion dollar piece of legislative
paper there's a new economic problem
people keep quitting their jobs my
mental health was more important former
preschool teacher brittany wimette is
one of a record 4.4 million americans
who left their jobs in september up from
4.3 million in august
at the end of september there were 10.4
million job openings in the u.s and
there's so many more ways to make money
than a nine-to-five job
um
and that that's what my job is now tired
of low pay and trying to juggle child
care with increasingly complicated covid
protocols at her school wimette found an
alternative that pays more and lets her
work from home part of it reflects
concerns about covid and exposure to
covid
treasury secretary janet yellen spoke
with face the nation moderator margaret
brennan about why there are so many
vacant positions on top of a worker
shortage the fact that child care
workers
educators are in short supply creates
child care problems that also tends to
suppress
labor supplies financial experts say
many workers are opting to retire early
and a september study by zip recruiter
found some 62 percent of job seekers
reported they are looking to change
their type of job and 55 percent are
trying to find a job they can do from
home
now next week president biden is
planning a big celebration for the
official signing of that transportation
bill and on the hill house democrats are
expecting to get back a budget analysis
that will help them get that larger
social spending plan the build back
better plan to a vote hopefully before
thanksgiving eureka
all right christina rafini for us not
quitting anytime soon i hope thank you
no definitely not you're stuck with me
thank you